three perverts have become the first
thruple
of men all to be listed on a baby's
birth certificate
how which one of them went through labor
which one pushed uh
it's a little complicated buckle up for
the most disturbing story that you have
heard
since tiger king i'm michael knowles
this michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from
old schooled who points out that the
left says
mother earth gives us life and the left
also says
not all people who give birth are women
that's true you currently have
a very famous catholic priest
misgendering god himself
so surely we can misgender mother earth
maybe it's daddy earth maybe
maybe earth is not just a single mother
or daddy but a throuple maybe we're the
child of this uh
inanimate earthly i don't know it's very
very complicated childbirth these days
and uh being raised in a culture that
has completely lost its common sense
in such a culture you're going to want
to protect yourself you can do that with
lifelock
if you use a free vpn virtual private
network for increased privacy when
online
you are probably going to want to
reconsider free vpns have been known to
harvest data and may expose your
personal information
this could make you vulnerable to
identity theft it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives in an
instant
a cyber criminal could take what's yours
your hard-earned money your credit your
reputation
good thing there's lifelock lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats like your social security number
for sale on the dark web i used to think
that
no one's really after my data right i'm
sure you think this too oh they're after
someone else's data
they're not mine when you realize how
much of your information is available on
the internet information you thought you
never gave
out you realize that this is a very
serious threat no one can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours with lifelock
identity theft protection
join now and save up to 25 off your
first year by going to lifelock.com
knowles that is lifelock.com knowles
canon wlas
to save 25 off i
did not believe this headline when i
first saw it i assumed that this was a
sensationalist headline
and that the story would actually be a
little more anodyne than
than the headline would make it out to
be but actually it's the opposite
the the story just gets worse and worse
and worse the more you read it headline
in the washing or in
the new york post rather gay polly
thrupple makes history lists
three dads on the birth certificate a
gay polyamorous california thruple
i i'd have to say the only part of this
story that i don't hate is the word
throuple because it's kind of funny
the reality not so funny but the word
it's funny to say throuple
a gay polyamorous california throuple
made history in 2017
when they became the first family in the
state to list
three parents on a birth certificate
their reproductive journey and legal
battle to become
fathers to piper now three is detailed
in three dads and a baby
out march 9th written by one of her dads
dr ian jenkins these three perverts
names are ian jenkins
jeremy hodges and dr alan mayfield
doctors so they're all look they're very
elite people they're
they're experts there there's no reason
to question their
degenerate behavior uh they don't see
their family which now also includes
their son parker as unusual
look it's not a big deal okay and then
they go on and explain
why this kind of uh child abuse is not a
big deal
love is love right love is love love is
love by the logic
of love is love
this makes some sense i said this at the
time when people were talking about
redefining marriage and they were trying
to turn it
from a basic question about the nature
of marriage
to a question about civil rights and
what you hate gay people and what you're
a mean old
guy or something i said by the logic
that is being pushed here there is no
limiting principle
scalia made this point too i mean the
conservatives at the the actual
conservatives at the time
of the obergefell decision made this
point they say this has nothing to do
with animus
for anybody because of sexual desires or
anything like that
we're simply asking what is marriage if
marriage has gone from being a
natural union of husbands and wives for
the for the
sort of tea loss of family creation
procreation
uh the basic political institution if it
if it goes from that
and then you take away the entire tea
loss
the entire purpose of that the the
entire uh
historical understanding of marriage and
the natural purpose of it
and it just means love is love then
there's no reason that it should only
include two people
forget the even the question of men or
women it
there's no limiting principle you could
have 10 people in a marriage if it's all
just about love is love and look they
love having a baby so what are you going
to limit that
what are you selfish this also shows the
question
to be a complete completely ridiculous
argument when sometimes
you'll hear mostly libertarians but
sometimes conservatives will say this
they'll say
look i don't want the government
involved in marriage anyway the
government
is involved in marriage in part not
least of all to prevent
this kind of child abuse but the
government failed to prevent that kind
of child abuse
sure because conservatives and
libertarians basically pulled away from
the entire debate and said we don't want
to use the government we don't want to
use our political power
we don't think that we should stop the
left from running roughshod over our
culture anyway so we've just handed the
reins of power over to the left
we shouldn't be surprised when they
abuse that power but the state
obviously has a role in this if the
family is the basic political
institution
then obviously any political
organization from the local to the
national level
is going to have some interest in that
institution
this is the most selfish
thing i have seen maybe ever certainly
the most selfish big news story i've
seen
ever some people are saying michael you
don't know if the child is going to be
abused you don't i'm not saying that the
the guys are all like the marquis de
sade and they're all going to start
doing all sorts of heinous things to the
baby i'm saying this
is the abuse this the whole thing
is the abuse initially
what what it seemed like these three
people were going to do
these three men was that they were going
to adopt
a fertilized embryo so a little
little miniature baby that are that was
frozen through various other
bioethically not totally sound
reproductive practices
and so they were going to adopt it
implant it into a surrogate
rent some woman's womb have the baby
grow and then
uh that would be the baby and that would
that would be bad enough
but it actually is a bioethically
different question because the embryo
already existed the baby was already
created and then thrown in a freezer
like happens
all too often today but then that didn't
work
according to this story the they tried
that a few times and the
babies died basically the little tiny
embryos died and so
what they did was their quote a friend
named megan came to the rescue and
donated her eggs to the trio
so what these guys did was they went out
and they created a baby
for the express purpose of
denying that child the ability to know
her mother ever and then
to be raised in a perpetual orgy
that's what they love is love right
this is the real tiger i don't mention
it only because i think this should be
illegal and these men should be in
prison
in a just society obviously not in our
society but in a just society that would
be the case
but that's not the only reason i
mentioned it the reason i mentioned it
has a broader cultural and political
point
this is tiger king what the
dominant liberal elite wants us to
believe is that
tiger king you know the the kind of the
the kind of crazy behavior and the
sexual
bizarre arrangements and all this kind
of selfishness
that that happens on a on a tiger farm
in florida you know it's florida man
it's the guy joe exotic with the mullet
and he talks funny
and he smokes a lot of meth or whatever
and he's in a he's in this exact
relationship he's in this sort of gay
throuple
uh no the real tiger king
culture happens with our elites
these guys are these are medical doctors
right i think so maybe they're just
using the term doctor
a little more broadly than that but
you've got two doctors these guys have
advanced education they seem to be
fairly well off because these processes
are pretty expensive
they are engaging in in far more
egregious behavior than any florida man
like joe exotic ever did the depravity
of our culture
does not come from the deplorable
irredeemable bitter clinging people in
the middle of the country who voted for
that fascist trump the depravity
far greater depravity comes from the
liberal elite
that pretends to be so much better than
us that tells us how to live
our lives think of the children as an
overused line and it is often exploited
by demagogues so i try to avoid the line
you know i don't want to sound like the
lady in the simpsons well
somebody please think of the children
however
there are some circumstances where you
actually need
to think of the children think of
what a selfish monster you have to be
to do this to a baby i mean i'm saying
i'm now seeing a baby
like quite a lot and a baby's keeping me
up quite a lot
a baby has an a right
to his parents sometimes you know
obviously kids are in bad circumstances
and
kids can be adopted in certain ways
let's not forget of course that there
are
something like 32 couples trying to
adopt for every baby up for adoption in
the united states
but this is a totally different to
create a baby
to deny the baby his mother to put them
to put these babies into this bizarre
selfish sexual situation absolutely
outrageous tommy tuberville
new republican senator made this point
on the senate floor he said you know
there there are times in this country
even if the line is overused
when you do have to think of the
children we've got to start teaching our
young people
moral values again that starts with
putting god
and prayer back in our schools our kids
need structure
and they need to learn right from wrong
i've watched everything that has
happened in education over the past few
decades
from a front row seat on my sideline as
a coach
it's embarrassing as a person who
chooses to spend their career in
education
i now have the opportunity to say
something as a united states senator
our young people are our number one hope
for this country's future
if we don't recognize that we're going
to lose our country
as we know it so what what tommy
tuberville is saying here it's not
some emotionally manipulative play he's
just he's stating a truism right the
children
the children are the future in as much
as
we're born we grow we die
and then the next generation rinses and
repeats right so
when you look i've been saying this for
years when you look at a university
campus
it's not like that's some little zoo and
then the kids are going to get fixed
when they get into the real world
you're looking at the future you're
looking at a crystal ball for your
country
so if children are educated to
exercise their moral conscience practice
the virtues learn their nation's history
love their country and develop their
faculties of higher
learning their higher reason that
is going to lead to one kind of a
country a good country if
on the other hand kids are not taught
even
sort of the rudimentary things
that will help develop their faculties
of reason and they're also taught a
bunch of cockamamie left-wing theories
about how terrible their country is and
about how
awful conservatives are or something and
how awful the founding fathers are
if they're taught that they can't even
discern right and wrong that you can't
trust your moral conscience
if you're taught that
you can't make judgments from the
natural world you can't make ethical
judgments then you're gonna have a
different kind of country you're gonna
have tiger king country
which these three perverts are showing
us pretty clearly
if you want to listen you know it seems
to me like we're kind of an underdog
country at the moment
the hope to have a really good thriving
country is an underdog battle right now
if you want to listen to a true underdog
story you gotta check out true underdog
podcast
raised in a trailer park with no clear
path to success kicked out of high
school multiple times and faced with
becoming a father in his teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog
after hearing the words no or you can't
too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies
with his most recent venture power home
solar skyrocketing on a path to becoming
a billion dollar enterprise
join us as waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year winner shares
motivational
tips and inspiring stories and business
building lessons
from the ground up he shares his life
experiences and that of his high profile
guests
to help others better themselves as
walter will tell you
there is no elevator to success that
climb only happens
one step at a time let every true
underdog podcast be that step that
elevates you
scared money won't make money learn
about failure learn about
entrepreneurship
learn about never quitting or making
excuses
it's real it's raw it's motivational
check out true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com or anywhere you get
your podcasts
go check it out right now
if children are the future unfortunately
we're getting some bad news from the
schools because the schools are going in
the other direction they are totally
failing students that is nothing new
but they're actually accelerating the
their efforts
to fail students and therefore fail our
nation's future
this from boston public schools
canceling
advanced classes because
why because of covid no it's actually
not because of covet
because of some issue with the
curriculum no it's not the curriculum
boston public schools are canceling the
advanced classes
because the students who make it into
those classes
are considered too white and too asian
fourth fifth and sixth graders will not
be accepted into advanced placement
classes
in boston for the next year because most
of the students a majority of the
students
are white or asian this program it's
called the advanced work classes
will suspend enrollment because of quote
concerns about
equity
this is what we have been told this has
become a cliche
about the left that the left
wants not to bring up the people who are
not doing as well but they want to bring
down the people who are doing well and
in this case they're doing it
through a process of explicit racial
discrimination
and they'll they'll defend it because
they have these theories about white
supremacy and they tell people that
white people are bad and they they push
a sort of
national ideology a governing ideology
of white guilt
but what about the asians you know even
if if
let's just say that the ideology of
white guilt is so ingrained that it's
going to be really hard to fight against
it and it's evil but you can understand
why this sort of thing is being allowed
in schools
what do the asians ever do there's no
ideology of asian supremacy or asian
guilt
why do these kids not get to go to their
advanced classes because other students
of other races don't do as well on the
placement tests
why are you going to punish the kids why
are you going to hold
them back that is a national pathology
john brennan who didn't i think he voted
for a communist for president once
seriously i'll i'll have to double check
that i was i always confused brennan and
clapper
but this guy really awful awful sort of
obama-era official brennan goes on
msnbc and
describes the guilt that he feels the
shame that he feels
not for all the terrible things he did
and all the stupid opinions he holds no
he feels the guilt and shame because of
his race and his sex
i must say to claire's point i'm
increasingly embarrassed to be a white
male these days like what i see
of my other white males saying wow oh my
gosh
so brave wow so brave and you can see
this woman she's one of the worst on
msnbc i forget her name is it nicole
wallace
she's giggling oh yes that's right talk
more about
those awful white men
oh we have to take them and throw
defenestrate them we need to throw them
bodily out of our country
in the name of racial and sexual
equality
pathetic it's very pathetic john brennan
is a
pathetic man but it's not just him who
holds this view this has become
a part of the national
the the this this idea that uh men are
bad and white people are bad
has really broken into the mainstream
from the fringes of the left now it's
it's pretty pretty mainstream this
narrative has been growing for a while
and it's it's the it's sort of the lens
through which we see a lot of our
our political history barack obama
actually worked this kind of racial
narrative into his biography from his
earliest days he's now doing this
absolutely insufferable podcast
with bruce springsteen which is somehow
those two guys bad enough in themselves
make each other worse
somehow the the sum is worse than the
individual parts
but barack obama was describing at this
time
that he was in in school in
hawaii and some kid called him a racial
slur
and he broke his nose when i was in
school i had a friend
we played basketball together and one
time we got in a fight and he called me
a co
wow now first of all ain't no questions
in hawaii right so
you know it's one of those things where
he might not even no one wanted
what he knew was i can hurt you by
saying this
and i remember i popped him in the face
and broke his nose
and we were in the locker room well done
and suddenly blood's pouring down
and it was just reactive i just yeah i
said what and i popped him
and he said why'd you do that
and i explained to him i said don't you
ever call me something like that
okay uh alex i'll take uh things that
never happened for 500
please i'm not saying nothing like this
ever happened but
politicians have a habit of exaggerating
stories over time obama in particular
biden for sure does that
barack obama already told a version of
this story in his first
book which was actually a pretty good
book dreams from my father have to hand
it to him
i i wouldn't i'm not saying run out to
the store and go read it but it's better
than the other stuff he's
written and said in his career and in
that version of the story
he just gave the kid a bloody nose now
you see it's being
heightened he broke his nose okay all
right fine
maybe maybe something like this happened
this narrative because the kid said a
racial slur
everyone's reaction to that is well
that's that's justified and i
actually sort of think if someone really
starts using fighting words
this sort of thing uh one one has their
limits on what they're going to take
and a culture that understands chivalry
and honor once understood that william f
buckley jr is as mainstream a
conservative as ever there was
had been called a nazi by gore vidal for
the umpteenth time on national
television and he famously said using a
slur not for
black people but for uh homosexuals he
said uh listen you queer
stop calling me a crypto nazi or i'll
smash you in your
face and you'll stay plastered too so uh
you know even even as mainstream a
conservative as that would say yeah
there are limits don't don't use these
fighting words
the point though that obama makes that i
think is really important here is
the kid didn't call obama that word
because the kid
hates black hated black people right and
obama's admitting that he makes this
point he says
there ain't no slurs for black people
in hawaii if you're in hawaii you're
kind of in a different
social milieu it's just a different
context
the kid called obama that word whether
in obama's fantasies or whether some
event like that happened in real life
because the kid was angry at obama and
he knew
that that word would hurt him
i i have on rarican there you know p
italians don't get called a lot of slurs
in america anymore they used to they
don't really anymore
uh unless you're chris woman you get
called fredo and you pretend that that's
an italian
slur but there have been a couple times
in my life i've been called an italian
slur
and i don't think it's because the
people who called me that
hate italians i don't think people
really harbor deep-seated hatred for
italians really anymore
uh they called me because i did
something that they didn't like or they
were just angry at me and so they said
okay what can i hit ugg
i can attack him for being a dude i can
attack him for being italian i can
attack him for
being just so so handsome i don't know i
don't know what was going through their
mind
this i think is very important when we
talk about
racism and this ism and that ism
not everything is a systemic
institutional problem
sometimes people just don't like you and
they're going to try to hurt you and
that's wrong
but it doesn't speak to a broader
pathology or a broader bigotry in this
country
and i think that as masculinity is also
now castigated as toxic
people are losing sight of this
men talk to each other in a rough way
and sometimes they're earnestly rough
and sometimes they're jokingly rough
i remember one time i was in college and
in my
suite you know all the guy with
different rooms kind of connected to a
common room
we were all just we were mean to each
other but we were good very good friends
we were all the same mean things to each
other one time there was a young lady
who was visiting our suite
and she heard the way we talked to each
other she said oh my gosh do you
hate each other i said what are we
talking about we're good friends right
better friends than most people on this
campus
that is something i think important to
keep in mind because we're about to hear
a whole lot about institutional racism
and systemic
bigotry because the trial of derek
chauvin the police officer who is
involved
in the death of george floyd that's
about to take place in minneapolis
and the city of minneapolis seems to be
gearing up
for world war three i mean you thought
that what they did at the capitol
in washington dc after this the january
6th riot
was intense they are locking this place
down in minneapolis
as though it is a fortress why because
maybe the facts of the case
are going to show that the blm narrative
that justified burning down cities
around the country for
six or eight months maybe that narrative
wasn't
totally true
which we will get to in just one second
but first got to tell you you got to
check out
ben's show today he's going to be
talking about the cancellation of dr
seuss you thought you thought
it was bad enough when they canceled
gina carano and they're going after dr
seuss now
go check that out you also got to check
out ben and daily wire's newest series
debunked every friday
then we'll expose popular fallacies
purported by left-wing
activists and politicians in the first
episode which is now available to daily
wire members ben debunks the myth of
minimum wage debunked is available
exclusively to daily wire members go to
dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off your new membership and stay tuned
for this friday's episode
where ben will break down unions that's
code debunked for 25
off we'll be right back with a lot more
the hennepin county district court
in minneapolis which will be holding the
trial
of the officer involved in the death of
george floyd has been quote
ringed with concrete barriers security
fencing
and barbed wire there is
increased security in the area including
the minneapolis police hennepin county
sheriff's deputies minnesota state
troopers
and the national guard what does this
mean it means they think that the cop is
going to get off
right if the cop is going to have the
book thrown at him
they're not going to need all this stuff
maybe they will maybe there will be
riots of celebration
but it seems to me all this security
measures all of these measures
suggest that the narrative we were told
about george st
george floyd who i think the
narrative being pushed by the mainstream
media was george floyd he wasn't on
drugs at the time george
floyd he didn't have a dodgy past
george floyd he wasn't resisting arrest
what the narrative was
george floyd is innocent as the newly
driven
snow and this cop
basically brutalized him to death
without any question
and maybe the cop acted inappropriately
i guess we'll find out in the trial
maybe all of the things that george
floyd had been doing
including the drugs most notably maybe
that didn't have any effect on his death
but the evidence we've seen so far from
autopsies and
other sort of evidence suggests that the
story is much more complicated
than the narrative would have led on and
maybe this cop is going to get off
because i think minnesota thinks that
he's going to get off
the city of minneapolis is hiring
black social media influencers
to push propaganda about the trial
this story came out just a few days ago
city city
of minneapolis would hire social media
influencers from local minority
communities to help facilitate the
spread of news
and combat misinformation during derek
chovan's trial
reportedly in the hopes to head off the
unrest
unrest one of the most orwellian words
in our language unrest meaning
violence and riots
this is just bribery right this is just
a sort of self-extortion the city of
minneapolis is extorting itself
and giving money to leaders in these
communities to try to buy their goodwill
and help
tell people in these communities not to
riot and torch the whole city
really a pathetic dereliction of
leadership from the city of minneapolis
that they they basically have to pay a
tribute to these local communities
not to burn down the whole city the city
of minneapolis has since announced
they're going to drop the plan
just yesterday they came out when this
came to light this
elicited enough bad looks all around
that they decided
that they were going to drop it but it's
a bad state
in our country where we have such a
an atrophied understanding of justice
that city officials have to bribe
local neighborhood leaders not to burn
down the city
ties into our understanding of justice
when you've got a throuple that's
permitted to create a child for the
explicit purpose of denying that child
the access to her mother designer babies
for their own
selfish reasons to to be put in a
perpetual
orgy of these three dudes speaking of
justice
merrick garland merrick garland looking
a little more radical than some of us
thought he was
garland as you know was supposed to be
the supreme court nominee
that obama put up to replace antonin
scalia and cocaine mitch held firm
and that's how we got more conservative
judges garland then went back to his
uh regular judgeship now he's being
pushed for the attorney general position
in biden's administration
when when he was named i thought okay
well could do a lot worse with these
radicals
so garland okay that's fine his answers
though have not impressed people
ted cruz one of the people who was uh
questioning him says that he's very
disappointed in garland's answers
he has built built a reputation for not
being overly partisan
and so i was hopeful that when judge
garland
came before this committee that he would
indicate
a commitment to the rule of law and a
commitment to standing up
to the hard politicization and
weaponization
of the justice department that we saw
during the eight years
of the obama biden administration
i have to say judge garland's testimony
before this committee and his subsequent
answers to the questions for the record
left me
deeply deeply disappointed on question
after question after question
judge garland refused to answer
virtually anything
this is the key here he wouldn't answer
so simple questions he just wouldn't
answer he'd punt he'd say we're going to
look at it we've got to review it
this this is the difference the the
radical left the openly radical left
like the aoc types they just tell you
exactly what they think
the moderate left like the joe biden
types they
don't tell you what they're going to do
but they're going to do the same thing
they're all going in exactly the same
direction merrick garland is probably
the most moderate biden nominee
and seems like he's a radical too jen
saki doing the same thing she was asked
a simple question
about what's going to happen to 600 to
800 000
migrants and what's her answer no answer
one other thing that the president of
mexico is expected to propose is
an idea to bring an immigrant labor
program to the u.s that could bring
600 to 800 000 immigrants a year to work
legally in the united states is that
something president biden would consider
i i've seen reports of that i believe
that's a step that would require
congress i'm sure we'll have a readout
after uh the
bilateral meeting this afternoon and
they both will be speaking after it as
well
sure the measure might involve congress
though frankly these days
since so much of the government is just
run by the executive agencies it
probably
doesn't need to involve congress but
just because it involves congress
doesn't mean that you can't give your
opinion on it if the matter involves
congress
that means that they're going to pass
some law about it and then the law has
to be either
signed or vetoed by joe biden so biden
absolutely needs to give his opinion on
this topic he's going to have a very
important role in it
so what's biden's opinion about sending
800 000
mexican immigrants each year to the
united states
to compete with american citizens for
jobs particularly with
lower wage americans for jobs
no answer no answer because he knows
that his answer
either way he answers is going to offend
either his base or the conservatives but
that he's going to slowly push this
policy immigration
broadly according to many public opinion
surveys
is a winning issue for republicans the
democratic
position on radical open borders
immigration is very unpopular
when you really drill down into the
details and so the democrats are going
to pursue it anyway because interest
groups
require them to and their electoral
future is greatly advantaged by that
but they're just not going to tell you
about it they're going to keep their
mouths shut same thing
saki was asked a question on the teacher
unions which
for no scientific reasons or keeping the
school's closed still
jansaki said his bidens or rather
shinsaki was asked as joe biden sold out
america to these unions
no answer one more question from uh
former president trump over the weekend
speaking at cpac
i heard that he he said
president joe biden sold out america's
children
to the teachers union how does the white
house respond to that
i think we're going to spend more of our
time focused on communicating
about our agenda for the american people
than responding to
criticism from the former president
this is not a terrible answer from jen
saki
because what you want to do when you're
asked a question like that
is to control the narrative right
michael do you still beat your wife you
know you want to
there's no way to answer that directly
that doesn't make you look bad
no i don't still beat my wife uh or yes
i well what huh
so you want to control the narrative you
want to control the wording here
however normally that strategy does
involve
smacking down the premise so if
the ideal answer to this question would
have been hey what do you say to trump
who says that
biden sold out america to the teacher
unions uh listen we got
the biggest uh amount of support
from grassroots people who oppose the
teacher unions we got a lot of support
from charter schools
we got a lot of support from parents
associations
so don't tell me about selling out
america and then maybe you punch back at
trump too and say he
took money from this group or that group
whatever
they didn't do that because they can
because joe biden sold out america to
the teachers unions
so she's there's really no good answer
and the teachers unions
they are as
dishonest and
disreputable as they possibly could be
they've never had a particularly good
reputation but now
they're flaunting their own rules the
berkeley federation of teachers
president matt meyer
has said that the teachers are not going
back until we have the gold
standard in berkeley california which
means that
all educators and staff have to be
vaccinated the schools have to enforce
social distancing
they have to enforce mask wearings all
the time
and until that basically impossible
standard
teachers get paid vacation right that's
that is the current line from the head
of the berkeley teacher union
yet he just got caught on video taking
his two-year-old daughter
to an in-person preschool because
he doesn't want to have to deal with the
consequences of his actions you see
what he wants is the best possible deal
for the teachers union but he also knows
that the arguments the teachers union
are making right now
or the arguments teachers union is
making is they're ridiculous arguments
they're the crazy on the on the virus
and he also knows that he wants to be
able to send his kid to school first of
all two-year-olds don't go to school i
know that it's very fashionable now
among sort of hip yuppies to say that oh
yes i'm going to send my 18 month old to
school no you're not you're sending them
to daycare
school doesn't start until you're five
and it's fine you can
like if it makes you feel better to say
oh yes you know yes my
my very advanced child is going to he's
taking advanced
classes uh for two-year-olds like okay
fine but it just it's daycare just for
for uh those of us who are interested in
the reality of it but it's obviously
hypocritical
it shows that the unions are not
actually worried
the unions do not care at all about the
science of it all
they just want to get money for doing
nothing they're just
lazy this is why good teachers tend to
hate the teachers
unions meanwhile turning to higher
education
the harvard business school club of new
york so this is sort of alumni
faculty at the harvard business school
they have cancelled
an event that they were going to host it
was going to be an academic lecture
and the academic lecture was going to be
on the topic of cancel culture
and because apparently the harvard
business school club of new york
thinks that cancel culture is such a
ridiculous topic they're going to cancel
the
lecture on cancer culture say that three
times fast
uh the speaker was going to be james
lindsay i think evan i think i've
interviewed james lindsay
uh he was one of the people involved in
uh
exposing the kind of silliness of
grievance studies and
he was worked with peter bogosian
now there's a big debate over cancel
culture and is this cancelled culture
and is cancelled culture even real
i just don't think i've said it a couple
times on this show i don't think
cancel culture is a helpful lens through
which to view this
situation this is all about standards
and power
this is all about having certain
standards getting back to our story at
the top of the show the thruffle
i think the throuple should be cancelled
i think that they should not be
permitted in polite society i don't
think they should be
invited to fancy dinner parties i think
what they're doing is
wicked and it's child abuse
and it's deeply unjust and they need to
get their act together
before people accept this kind of
insanity as acceptable
am i therefore a proponent of cancer
culture no any sensible person
until about five minutes ago any
sensible person would have said that
this is
absolutely outrageous wrong
and should not be tolerated by a just
society but now we've fallen for this
trap and it's a trap i've
also mentioned it happens to be the
thesis of my book speechless controlling
words controlling minds
which is when the left pushes political
correctness they do it to get rid of the
old standards
and the only ways that conservatives
ever react is we go along with the new
left-wing standards or we abandon
standards altogether and we say you do
you there should be no limits on what we
do
or think or say or anything like that
and that just has no basis
in american history
bill maher is getting a lot of credit
right now
because he's coming out and defending
gina carano my colleague i never thought
that i would have a colleague
in political media who was an mma
fighter and a disney movie star
but hey you know this is a pretty weird
time that we're living in and gina
carano
was fired from disney just for being a
conservative right and they they used
as an excuse some social media posts
she'd made but the social media posts
were completely
innocuous they were inoffensive they
didn't they didn't really say anything
wrong at all
and so bill maher who is a man of the
left
is defending her and saying she
shouldn't be canceled and bill maher is
doing this this is
very much in his wheelhouse because
even though he's a left winger he's
always sort of opposed political
correctness or at least he thinks he
does
he had he hosted a show called
politically incorrect
he's he's uh not not of the hard left
but he's not a conservative either and
he's making an argument that while i
appreciate it and i'm glad he's standing
up
for a conservative here against the
left-wing mob i don't think the argument
is particularly effective
so bill maher is defending gina carano
on the grounds that she did not deserve
to be canceled take a listen
the mandalorians gina carano is a person
i'd never heard of and resent that i
have now
she's some conservative wrestling chick
who kicks ass on a show
i wouldn't watch if i was in prison
and she made some nazi analogy who
doesn't these days
you're like the nazis is the new i don't
like you
it's always okay with trump's nazi that
disqualifies her for marching around
planet who gives a [ __ ] in a helmet
by the way you can't work in hollywood
if you don't believe
what we believe yeah in the 50s that's
exactly what the left
complained they were being told so this
is a funny bit i
laughed a couple times while while
watching it the first time and i'm
really i
really do appreciate that bill would
stand up for a conservative who's being
canceled by the left-wing mob
but it's that argument there at the end
that that means i can't totally go along
with him
he says you know in the 50s this is what
leftists complained about and what he's
referring to is anti-communism
and the anti-communism of the 1950s is
something that has been
totally rewritten by left-wing
historians
who are still trying to cover up the
fact that they were defending the
communists in in the
30s 40s and 50s this is sometimes called
mccarthyism
and mccarthyism is sometimes conflated
with blacklisting in hollywood
senator joe mccarthy had absolutely
nothing to do with hollywood
blacklisting
no person of any political persuasion
whether they love mccarthy or hate
mccarthy
who has actually looked at the facts can
say mccarthy had something to do with
the blacklisting in hollywood mccarthy
had nothing to do with
huak better known or i suppose it's
better known as huac now but it ought to
be known as the house committee
on un-american activities what happened
in the 1950s
and really more in the 30s and 40s is
that the soviet
government our enemies in the cold war
had spies placed
throughout the federal government had
very high level spies in the federal
government this is not a conspiracy
theory
we know this we ended up rooting out a
couple hundred of them
at least the most notable one is alger
hiss
who was a high-level state department
official he had been at the doj
he helped found the united nations he
was directly working for the soviet
union
he was a spine in the united states if
you want to read a good book about it
you can read witness
by whitaker chambers at the time this
was a hotly debated political issue
because
the republicans were the the ones who
were hardcore anti-communists here
and the communist problem festered
during democratic administrations in
fact the reason dwight eisenhower got
elected
was because of the the backlash
against democrats going soft on
communism
john f kennedy defended joe mccarthy
bobby kennedy
went to joe mccarthy's funeral it was
absolutely right and just
for the united states to root out
communists
in the 1930s 40s and 50s it was a matter
of
great national importance was that
cancel culture
sort of you know it this is so crazy to
me for the conservatives who
just sort of maybe reflexively because
they believe whatever they were taught
in public school
the ones who decry mccarthyism who buy
the left's line on mccarthyism
conservatives out of one side of their
mouth will decry
the cultural marxism of hollywood and
the universities
and say that we've got to take back the
institutions and we can't let these
leftists destroy our culture through
hollywood and through
the universities and then at the same
time
they'll decry mccarthyism and cancel
culture and say that
we can never root out anybody we just
need to debate them in the free
marketplace of ideas
when you say that we need to take back
the institutions take back hollywood
take back the universities
what you are saying is we need to get
the leftists
out of those places we need to
censor them in a certain sense we need
to kick them out of their positions of
influence
on the basis of their ideological views
you are defending a sort of mccarthyism
but then on the other hand you say but
we would never do that sort of thing the
leftists are the new macarthists in
reality what
happens is people defend their standards
and no society is perfectly open and
nobody believes that if a guy walks up
to his water cooler at the office with
an armband
the swastika screams zig kyle that he
has any right to keep his job and and
the debate that's really happening right
now is over which set of standards we're
going to have
the good set of standards that defends
america and defends
our faith and defends our traditions and
our way of life
or the bad set of standards which says
america's evil and americans should be
divided and hate one another and
uh degenerate throuples should be able
to create designer babies without any
care for the child himself
or herself which set of standards are
you going to defend
because if we have the good traditional
moral version then you can't have the
trouble version you actually have to
exclude that
you have to say no you have to cancel
that and it would be a very good thing
to cancel that speaking of a guy who's
getting canceled for weird sex stuff
andrew cuomo i have to touch on this
story andrew cuomo is in trouble right
now
because of allegations of sexual
harassment a new video has resurfaced
showing that andrew cuomo was harassing
a reporter and told her to eat a sausage
sandwich a sausage hoagie at a new york
political event take a listen
will you eat the whole food sandwich
yeah
in front of you but i'm definitely
[Music]
well that's right
okay so this is now being blown up as a
horrible sexual harassment the woman
says she
didn't feel sexually harassed at all she
enjoyed it cuomo bought her a
sausage and they made jokes about eating
on camera which is a real joke if you
talk to presidential candidates
they will tell you when you go to the
iowa state fair don't eat the corn dog
it just doesn't look good on camera
andrew cuomo should be canceled because
he killed thousands of elderly new
yorkers
and then covered up their deaths when
the federal government started poking
into it
that's why he should be canceled maybe
some of these sexual harassment claims
are
are legit i don't know they seem kind of
politically convenient right now
and this one seems kind of bogus to me
the reporter
is perfectly happy uh i'm all for
getting rid of andrew cuomo i think
that's fine he's a bad governor
but it's a it says something about our
standards now where if you kill
thousands of elderly new yorkers and
cover it up
because you know what a scandal it is
you're totally fine but if you make a
joke about a sausage at a political
event
that's going to ruin your life it shows
us that something about our standards
has gone orion maybe we're going to have
to try to recover that i'm michael
nolan's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021. today on the ben shapiro show
chris cuomo realizes that covering his
brother andrew for cnn was a bad idea
and dr
seuss is canceled that's today on the
ben shapiro show check it out